makes you all gonna come in thank you
very much speakers for for coming for
obliging us by coming making time and
very busy schedules in a very busy time
of year I'm Victoria grazie I'm the
director of the blinkin European
Institute and this is an occasion that
requires just a minute of explanation
first of all in high note invited this
you all to this implanted thinking it's
our intellectual obligation to discuss
something which is so significant for
the u.s. foreign policy for Syria for
all the notions of global justice and
human rights which are so much in debate
and so in that sense of the engage
intellectual we don't have anymore
unfortunately the kind of teaching
events that we used to have this in some
sense is a surrogate it's also part of
the blinking European Institute's
mandate to buy which was found in and
out to address questions that have to do
with public diplomacy and we've been
trying in terms of our mandate which
does require us also to think very much
about Europe to consider problems of
soft power hard power the interface
between them the questions of Human
Rights the new diplomacy and so this in
some sense is the first event of this
year obligatory insofar as there are
force measure which would demand it also
on other grounds and we will be having
other occasions we have returning
ambassadors from Europe mix of public
diplomacy and critiques of public
diplomacy as its practice
in the United States but also globally
over the course of the year let you know
about those hey so today let me
introduce our panel first of all I'd
like to introduce Stuart Gottlieb who is
an adjective professor of international
affairs and public policy sepa he
teaches courses on American foreign
policy counterterrorism and
international security and he got his
PhD here from Columbia in international
relations he's worked in as we say the
public sector in the United States
Senate as a policy advisor also to
Senator Schumer of New York and also to
Christopher Dodd of Connecticut a second
edition of his book debating terrorism
counterterrorism complete conflicting
perspectives on causes context and
responses is was published very recently
april 2013 and he's working now on a
book titled experimental power the rise
of role of america and world affairs
which were very much looking forward
yeah in terms of our purpose is that i'd
like them to introduce next gene Cohen
who's got her PhD from New School for
Social Research before we need to talk
about issues presently professor the
nail and herbert singer professor of
political thought at columbia anything
no room for work on critical theory on
civil society human rights gender
recently her celebrated her book here
criticized it Paul audited on
globalization sovereignty rethinking
legality and legitimacy and
constitutionalism she's now working with
the blinking Institute on her volume
political religion legal pluralism
democratic citizenship which will come
out with Columbia University in 2014
I can bali-ba is a professor emeritus of
moral political philosophy at the
University of Paris tan non tear and
distinguished he's been distinguished
professor of humanities at the
University of California Irvine we are
very grateful to have him come
repeatedly to Columbia where he's a
visiting professor in the Department of
French and romance philology he's
published vary widely in the area of
marcus philosophy and more generally
moral political philosophy and his
latest works include reflections refix
youngster immediacy or LPN and your
Constitution from and frontier 2005 very
pleased to have him and jean-marie G&O
doesn't seem to be here yet so we hope
you will be coming and I will introduce
him at that moment and Jack Snyder was
also received his PhD from Columbia by
that it's not an important thing that
he's Robert Renee belfair professor of
international relations he's an expert
on international relations and on Soviet
post-soviet area written widely on
crisis diplomacy democratization and
very very pleased that he is able to be
here and I will now wait for one second
Professor Ian oh thank you so much
director for the center for
international conflict resolution and
seat by though this is end of class
moment so real breathing hard had to
have gotten here and presently the
Associate Director for the Saltzman
Institute for war and peace studies he's
also senior fellow from Brookings
Institute Institute he's published
widely on impact of globalization on
strategy globalization and international
system I'm very very grateful for you to
be here what we're going to be doing is
starting a sort of accumulation we're
going to be starting with Stuart
everybody will be speaking about seven
minutes and then we will continue in the
way of discussion debate unfortunately I
have to leave at five twenty which what
Chris Hill who's the associate director
of the blinkin European Institute step
in to mediate which will surely be a
very lively discussion debate thanks
appreciate it I'm going to begin by
reading from the account of an observer
of the poison gas attacks of which were
now all too familiar in some cases quote
special discharge devices were built
into the Rockets so they could vaporize
over vast territory of fine
death-dealing gas groups of rockets
followed one another so that the fog
issued from them formed a continuous
sheet as men women and children were
drenched with this deadly poison the
very refinement of barbarism consisted
in carrying ravage and terror into the
most densely populated part of the
country the object was to scatter fear
and death these fearful tactics
succeeded the deadly gas made all those
whom it touched shriek in pain and
thousands to die in the most dreadful
suffering unquote these were not words
from an observer on the ground in Syria
in August these are this is from only a
slightly edited version of Haley
Selassie the Emperor of Ethiopia in his
june thirtieth 1936 address to the
League of Nations in Geneva when he
described the
for criminal unquote the quote criminal
use unquote of poison gas by Mussolini's
invading Italian Army and the pan when
he passionately begged the world to come
to the assistance of Ethiopia now I
should note that both Italy and Ethiopia
were parties to the League of Nations
treaty I should also note that both
Italy and Ethiopia were parties to the
1925 Geneva protocols banning the use of
chemical weapons in warfare and Selassie
concluded his address by decrying the
famous global in action in the face of
the slaughter in Ethiopia that the
nations of the world community turning
their collective backs ignoring their
supposed international obligations to
act under the League of Nations treaty
and Geneva protocols Hayley Selassie
concluded his address with a series of
pointed questions which I will only
slightly paraphrase as if not now when
and if not here where and he concluded
by saying if not on behalf of Ethiopia
do you not realize it might soon be you
was how he ended this now much has
changed in the world since 1936 and the
debating society of the League of
Nations has been replaced by a much more
realistic and therefore a much more
effective global peace and security
organization known as the United Nations
more specifically the UN Security
Council and the case can be made that
over the past several decades there's
been an evolution in norms and
principles now embodied in international
law that helped guide in shape state
behavior more in the direction of
respect for human rights and
humanitarian principles and to
potentially compel States to act
internationally on behalf of those
principles but as the Syria case
explicitly shows issues surrounding
military intervention on moral grounds
are enormously complex and there are no
easy answers regarding what direction
the world is currently going with
respect to establishing universal norms
and standard practices of behavior when
it comes to humanitarian intervention
particularly military intervention into
sovereign states confronting rebellion
and civil war there are two competing
and sometimes complementary forces here
one are straight global humanity
such as prohibition on genocide that
when violated may call for outside
intervention and secondly there are
hybrid global humanitarian and security
norms such as prohibition on use of
chemical weapons that aside from the
clear humanitarian component are also of
broader security concern for major
powers because of the harmful precedent
that weapons of mass destruction use
would set for their possible future and
further use the use of chemical weapons
in particular though not as deadly as
other WMD like biological or
radiological or nuclear can be seen in
if you want to think of it this way is a
gateway drug potentially to bigger and
worse WMD so it's a core global security
concern as well as being a humanitarian
concern so so sort of a clash of norms
going on here humanitarian norms versus
security norms this tension defines the
case of Syria let's not forget that
there was no talk of direct military
intervention into Syria even after a
hundred thousand civilians were killed
over two years in a bloody rebellion and
a brutal government counter rebellion
talk of direct military intervention
only came into play with the question of
use of chemical weapons as the two norms
merged the norm of humanitarian
intervention itself and norms regarding
the spread and use of WMD generally the
Obama administration's are often
confused and I would almost call it a
spaghetti on the wall approach to Syria
is evidence of this on the one hand
Secretary of State John Kerry has mostly
spoken of the quote moral obscenity
unquote of chemical weapons use by the
Assad regime implying that US military
strikes were justified on moral grounds
alone while Obama has mostly spoken
about what he refers to as the quote
global norm unquote against the use of
WMD in war implying that military
strikes were justified not just on the
moral case but also on the strategic
case if this isn't confusing enough
there's another complicating factor that
hovers over the entire question of not
just moral intervention in Syria but of
moral intervention in general
and that's the 2011 Libya intervention
which was sold on the grounds of a
purely humanitarian intervention the
so-called responsibility to protect or
the r2p principle but quickly became a
regime change operation and that
enterprise threw a monkey wrench into
all of these big questions Syria can
only be understood in the context of and
under the long shadow of the extremely
problematic Libyan intervention which I
hope we have a little time to get into
because I might not be able to get into
it as much as I like in this opening
before I I will briefly get us from
Libya to Syria but let me just at least
touch on the context here very very
briefly people who know this the context
of of the current humanitarian
intervention questions and the
difficulties of them starts with the
United Nations system which was created
in 1945 but the UN system has built in
contradictions that are really important
for this discussion on the one hand the
UN Charter upholds the Westphalian model
of primacy of state sovereignty and
articles 24 and articles 27 for example
protect and defend the states right only
the state government has the right to
intervene on behalf of peace and
security in its own borders so the
westphalian system is alive and well in
the UN Charter with the assumptions that
states are the sole legitimate
guarantors like I said of peace and
security in their own borders and I
don't want to bury the lead here two of
the five permanent members of the UN
Security Council China and Russia view
this as the cornerstone of the
legitimacy of the organization itself
but there are contradictions as we know
competing clauses such as article 55
which talks about respect for principle
of equal rights and self-determination
and human rights and article 56 which
talks about all members have an
obligation to act on behalf of human
rights and and other what we think of
ism as enlightened principles in recent
years especially since the 90s since the
in since the civil wars in the former
Yugoslavia and Rwanda there's been a
major effort at consensus building
regarding
intervention based on articles 55 and 56
which has led to evolution of so-called
r2p principle now not everyone agrees
with this evolution realists and even
some supporters of humanitarian
intervention say that moving too far too
fast with these principles can actually
undercut the possibility of long-term
success of these supposedly evolving
principles of humanitarian intervention
so these are very complicated issues I'm
going to simplify just a couple more
things briefly because we have to
remember that the ultimate decisions
regarding whether or not military
intervention on moral grounds will take
place these decisions are going to come
from States making these decisions in
their capitals states are the entities
that will ultimately expend the treasure
and possibly blood and in the case of
democracies possibly against popular
opinion at home and a great political
risk as we recently have seen in the
British Parliament and the US Congress
and to narrow it down even further there
are only a relatively small number of
states in the world who have the
capacity to project note the kind of
military power on a global scale that
might be needed in a military
intervention for humanitarian purposes
let's narrow it down even further than
that it's really the p5 countries on the
UN Security Council that better the top
five military powers in the world and
also have a veto capacity in that
organization and the United States as
one of the p5 members has more military
capacity than all of the rest combined
so these are the actors that will
ultimately be the most important in
making this decision which is what
separates the United Nations from the
League of Nations system where you have
power that plays a role on the UN
Security Council but it also could
potentially lead to a tremendous amount
of stalemate when those great powers
disagree so the question is if the great
powers disagree on a course of action
what do you do are you are you stuck
like a deer in the headlights as 120,000
people die if China and Russia don't say
that it's okay to you know to intervene
we can get back to Libya maybe a little
bit later but the Libyan intervention
spooked countries like China
China Russia but also India Brazil Arab
League countries and other countries
that saw that as initially a protecting
civilians in Benghazi quickly turned
into a regime change operation and they
took the first opportunity that they
could in October of 2011 to vote against
a very watered-down resolution just
condemning the violence in Syria in
general they voted against that to make
a stand saying we think any any
resolution coming out discussing
internal goings on of a sovereign
country it could potentially lead to
another Syria outcome and it's very
difficult very difficult to get past
Russia and China on the Security Council
and some I'm going to just wrap it up
with this with this point I could bring
it up a little bit later if people are
interested some say if Russia and China
don't approve then there's nothing that
can be done States can't take take it on
themselves to enforce and protect you
know international law there was an
op-ed a couple of weeks ago by a couple
of yale law professors una Hathaway and
Scott Shapiro that that made that exact
case that if the United States acted if
the United Sates did the military strike
said Obama threatened to do that would
violate international law it would be
illegitimate and they said unless the UN
Security Council authorizes it it's
illegal instead of military strikes they
said there's plenty that the world can
do to protect the Syrian public let me
give you an example of one of them they
said instead of bombing illegally the
Syrian regime Obama should instead work
with Congress to do much more for Syrian
rebels and refugees including providing
antidotes to nerve agents which are in
short supply unquote so instead of the
United States acting to retaliate
against the use of chemical weapons they
suggested something that I think would
be far short of what humanitarian
humanitarianism was calling out to do
now I responded to that I bet I had a
piece in The New York Times the next day
criticizing them saying that uh you know
if you hold the UN Security Council to
that standard it will revert back to the
League of Nations system of a constant
stalemate and inaction
and then you we will have the
unfortunate situation which we probably
already do actually I know we already do
of Syrian rebel leaders not the
al-nusrah types but some legitimate
folks that are opposing the regime
asking the same question as as thousands
more die by the week if not here where
and if not now when okay there will
probably be some overlap but that's good
because there's also some disagreement
already Isis bhandup will increase
nature that we increase both alright um
the issue of humanitarian military
intervention in a sovereign state that
has apparently used van chemical weapons
against its citizenry raises as Stewart
said complex moral legal and political
questions the first moral question that
arises is general and abstract while
also being substance substantive what
threshold of violations of international
law killing of civilians crimes against
humanity and our human rights violations
has to be crossed to suspend a
sovereignty argument against
international intervention and count as
a de feasibly sufficient ground for
possibly taking action against violators
that would not otherwise be permissible
or normatively available there are some
general there is some general general
agreement that what I call in my recent
book of mine on globalization
sovereignty the four es mass
extermination expulsion ethnic cleansing
and it's an enslavement are not deemed
to be within the domain domain reserved
a of sovereign states today and that the
international community has a
responsibility to protect r2p which was
just mentioned to protect individuals
from such action by states in which they
reside or our citizens the use of
chemical weapons especially against the
civilian population bead in a civil war
or otherwise certainly seems to be above
the threshold indeed the idea of r2p the
nine sovereign immunity regarding such
crimes was articulated in the UN 2005
outcome document unanimously endorsed by
the General Assembly mentioning for
possible triggers for
concern and intervention genocide war
crimes ethnic cleansing crimes against
humanity however the substantive moral
question of thresholds moon is
inextricably linked to a procedure war
procedural one who decides if or when
such a threshold has been reached and
who may act ie intervene militarily to
put a stop to it the RTP document just
mentioned restricted the question of
right authority the old Just War concept
to make such assessments regarding
threshold and the decision to use course
of means to the Security Council this
brings me to the legal questions raised
by humanitarian intervention generally
and the Syria case in particular forgive
II if I remind you and you already did
that but in another way I deal typically
of two stages of international law the
one dominant from the 19th century till
1945 and one that the one that exists
today ever since the construction of the
UN Charter system along with other
treaties and forms of humanitarian law
but I want to make a point in so doing
prior to the UN Charter system what was
known perhaps misleading as the
westphalian sovereignty model ascribed
sovereign states and international
society the right to war the right to
self-help immunity from outside
intervention international and internal
affairs impermeable domestic impermeable
domestic state power the black box among
other prerogatives two things are worth
stressing Duchscherer each sovereign
state could decide for itself if it
suffered aggression and if any violation
of international law regarding its
interests had occurred and each
sovereign state was deemed the right
authority ie the decider to quote
someone and the actor who writes the
wrong self-help in this decentered
international legal system each state
could declare and engage in war if it
deemed it necessary to correct any
violation of its sovereignty or
sovereign interests in addition how the
sovereign state regulated its internal
affairs and treated its own citizens or
those under his control was not the
business of outsiders de facto this
meant that the Great Powers decided on
war and of course as is well known many
of these were European Imperial and/or
imperialist states who intervened in non
sovereign states
to war occupied and sometimes the next
those defeated and exercise Imperial
Dominion and colonial rule in the
aftermath of two world wars genocide and
so forth the second half of the 20th
century witnessed an unprecedented
effort to legally regulate the use of
force and install a collective security
regime well it took some decades formal
formal empires were disbanded and all
the new states now I think under 93 I
always get that number or 192 formed out
of the debris of European empires and
were ascribed sovereignty by the
international system and sovereign
equality with its corollaries of
non-intervention self-determination and
political economy autonomy became the
norm I don't think this is a West
filling dimension of the UN Charter
system but we can debate that however
the UN Charter system of which most if
not all sovereign states are members
also installed a new sovereignty regime
with three key differences from the
previous models States no longer have
the right to war international
aggression is banned and Human Rights
affirmed the regime of self-help is
replaced according to the new norms by
collective security which was mentioned
and its correlative principles of
sovereign equality and non-intervention
the UN Charter allows only two
exceptions to this rule self-defense if
a state is or is about to be attacked
and this does not include the right to
preventive war that was rejected by the
UN outcome document and chapter 7 powers
ascribed to the UN Security Council to
sanction aggression you and use military
force if necessary to maintain
international peace and security so the
right authority is now firmly lodged in
the in the Security Council the
principles of self-determination and
political autonomy do not however entail
immunity from international concern and
there has been important shifts have
been important shifts in the conception
of what should be in the Dominican
survey of any sovereign state as the UN
summit document indicates humanitarian
intervention per se is not black letter
international law and that document only
has a status of a general assembly
resolution but it's indisputable that
under contemporary international law or
norms it is the Security Council that
decides when violations of international
humanitarian law against genocide
including crimes against him
the illegal use of chemical weapons or
other internal aggressions against one's
own citizenry crosses the threshold and
becomes a matter of international
concern and possible military sanction
if it gets cast as a threat to
international peace and security this is
the current international legal
normative the security system we have
today now some insist that this system
is dysfunctional they claim that in the
face of humanitarian disasters chapter 7
mechanisms have remained a dead letter
even after the Cold War thanks to the
veto power of the p5 on the council
especially Russia and China indeed some
more humanitarians argue that in cases
of serious violations any state able and
willing to put a stop to them should for
them council votes against humanitarian
intervention prove that the tron
mechanisms don't work and then tallit in
international legal norms unmoved but
this logic is flawed just because one
loses a vote or as soon as one will lose
a vote in favor of military intervention
in a particular case for example Syria
now doesn't mean that the system is
inoperable or that there is no viable
international law it just means you lost
the vote or would lose the vote to be
sure law requires some efficacy and as
was just indicated as a matter of fact
the circular cat Security Council has
voted for interventions post 1989 on
several occasions Iraq Gulf War
Afghanistan and Libya whatever we think
of all that so obviously losing a vote
doesn't cannot be the criteria for
whether chapter 7 mechanisms work or not
to follow that logic would be doubly
regressive it would mean returning to
the old and discredited sanction theory
of law that confuses a legal moment the
sanction or efficacy and it would drag
us back to the pre-world War one even
system albeit in a new Imperial form
although as already indicated the
westphalian system was imperial as well
ensure it would give the green light to
powerful imperial mind the states to
decide and to intervene if they so which
hardly an inviting prospect since we
should all know by now that there are no
disinterested humanitarian heroes out
there I mean states among the great
powers does this mean I'm and amending
sort of like you does this mean although
differently
does this mean that I embrace legalism
and think nothing can be done when
there's large scale killing of domestic
populations or violations of
international law and universal norms as
in the Syrian case of the use of
chemical weapons what if the killing
gets past the threshold of the morally
intolerable what I stick to legalism
just because a veto by state in the
Security Council pursuing its own do
political goals here we have to be very
careful to avoid both moralistic
absolutism and rigid legalism my answer
is that yes we must think in terms of
the spirit and not only the letter of
the law this means that military action
contemplated by a powerful state to stop
atrocities would have to satisfy at
least three and more criteria to be
legitimate a it would have to have very
broad international support be domestic
approval of representative bodies if it
has any see they would have to be a
sufficient coalition of states willing
sounds familiar right now to engage in
the action and to follow international
law in the aftermath unlike what
happened in Libya this couldn't could
lend the action legitimacy in cases of
urgency even if it's illegal and indeed
it would have to be judged afterward
unappropriate gowns grounds a kind of ex
post facto jury but and this is crucial
political judgment also has to enter
into the fray by political judgment I
mean ethical and pragmatic / strategic
calculations clearly any intervention
that would spur sibley make matters
worse in terminal e or do politically in
the neighborhood or strengthen the hands
of actors equally heinous would be
unacceptable so an ethical
responsibility must inform the decision
to act rather than a moralistic ethic of
convention conviction which disregards
possible consequences second we must
never forget that in the domain of the
political what matters is getting the
key players to the bargaining table and
arriving at a political settlement for
which compromise rather than absolutism
must be the watchword interest and not
only morals of legal norms or principles
are always at play and have to be
considered the purpose of an
intervention especially in the heat of
its still of a civil war civil war but
not only
is not to punish but to stop and prevent
further violations so pragmatism the
intelligent use of law has to be brought
together with principal I leave it to
the IR people one already preceded me on
the panel to discuss the do politics of
the Syrian situation for now it looks
like the threat of force rather than its
use especially if coupled with the
Security Council resolution and
international consensus on what to do
next maybe our and the Syrian civilians
greatest hope thank you very much so I'm
not he got serious i'm not a political
theorist i'm not completely sure that it
philosopher has a relevant opinion on in
matters of political judgment i very
much agree with jean on that so when I
was asked to take part in this panel
apart from being of course greatly
honored and hoping to come out with
fewer ideas I had to wonder how I could
intervene and I came to the conclusion
that the only thing I could do would be
to express my doubts and reactions and
ultimately my pessimism as a citizen
kind of counted if you like so I tried
to put this in the form of four
successive points the first of them and
you'll see I'm barely doing more than
stating the obvious but each other's way
to do it his or her and first point is
this is stating the obvious but perhaps
worth recalling the Assad regime is a
cruel dictatorship
which for which we can have or at least
I think we can have absolutely no
complacency I say this because in the
international discussion that is
developing these days and I receive
links to articles or expressions from
different parts of the world including
the Arab world the fact that this regime
has origins which can be called
anti-imperialist in a broad sense
representing originally a secular
perhaps even a socialist branch of Arab
nationalism is sometimes invoked in my
view this doesn't confer upon it any
progress progressive or positive value
even if some of us including myself are
suspicious of the consequences of a
conquest of power by some of its
adversaries particularly the Islamist
groups which are more or less directly
subsidized by the petro monarchies of
the Gulf and so the next point is that
the rebellion are they revolt the
revolution term is also justified i
believe of a great important part of the
syrian population was entirely
legitimate and it has also to be noticed
that it remained a peaceful
rebellion for a very long time before a
an extremely brutal repression started
to change the situation but the problem
is that this rebellion or revolution has
now become transformed into a civil war
which has no apparent solution at the
same time because of its being invested
by internal ethnic religious divisions
of the Syrian society itself and above
or because of external interventions
including of course Russia and
indirectly at least the Western powers
who trained troops and money and weapons
and so on so this is an
instrumentalization of the situation
that completely changed its character
it's impossible not to take into account
this situation I believe if one begins
to think about the possible consequences
of new interventions in the forum in one
or another form as a consequence of this
first first point I want to insist on
the fact that there has already taken
place an intervention from outside in
Syria which some people judge of course
insufficient and others catastrophic
this is perhaps not foreign to the fact
that in the end it seems to be leading
now to something like a bargaining
between the most powerful of the
external parts involved namely Russia
and the United States second point I
have to accelerate to describe and
justify in advance the strike oh no
that's not possible the strikes that are
now suspended and which have been
described in different words the French
and the Americans did not exactly have
the same the official motive was the use
of gas military combat gas dicamba which
are prohibited by the international law
and the fact that Assad i quote gassed
his own people I'm trusting neither the
American or more generally Western
secret services and of course not the
arguments that the Russians opposed to
that I trust a little more the United
Nations experts but I have a tendency to
think that even if this of course is not
per se a material proof Assad just like
his father before was perfectly able to
do that the question is therefore to
know whether the use of combat gazes in
a civil war by forms or built the red
line of threshold for the international
community to intervene it is known that
the inclusion of such weapons in the
category of weapons of mass destruction
is disputable and is actually disputed
what I think is that the criterion at
the same time moral and political is the
amplitude of the massacres and the
destructions and from that point of view
the possible use of these gas is part of
a modular or a picture it is to the jet
the massacres perpetrated by the Assad
regime and perhaps also of course today
some war crimes committed by part of the
resistance that we should try to find a
parade a parade of which we have to be
reasonably sure that it will not produce
consequences which are even worse than
what they were supposed to prevent a
very difficult argument of course to
use it doesn't seem that the announced
interventions offered that guarantee
they were rather linked to they were
rather linked to a strategic calculus
which I needed the basic question and
principal question is to know what one
thinks of the very idea of humanitarian
intervention and the responsibility to
protect my position on the on this point
in the dualism that Dean Cohen describes
in her book or to her intervention
between the abstract westphalian and the
abstract cosmopolitan her point is
rather in favor of this right and duty
to intervene in given a circumstance
a--'s of whose extreme character of
course has to be identified and there's
a long story of cases throughout the
20th century which in my opinion
demonstrate that this is of course
directed against the Schmidt Ian kind of
sovereign ideology that many even
progresses in the Arab world lead that
lead many of progressive people to
unfortunately see as sad as a good guy
because he's resisting in the name of
national independence but the following
question is who can and who may
intervene the Western powers and
particularly the United States of
America are especially ill placed to do
that even if of course Putin has no
lesson to teach them for three reasons
at least first the long history of the
American interventions in the world
shows that they never had any other
objectives than their own interest or at
the very least the never left his
interests aside President Obama has
admitted this even recently second
American saw are probably the greatest
users of weapons of mass destructions
are prohibited
weapons some analysts prefer and I like
this expression weapons of
indiscriminate this destruction gasps
combat for ten years in Vietnam and
others more recently third in spite of
fruit creations in the language from one
administration to another American
interventions are linked to the idea of
a mission or a special and exceptional
responsibility in the world affairs in
other terms an imperial posture which
claims to be most of the time above
international law and as a consequence
the United Nations as well of course
there's a tension here in my position I
acknowledge and finally I'm sorry for
the length final point but I think it's
important we come to the question to
decide whether it's a good thing that
the clever coup that has been played by
the Russians to really JIT amis the
Assad regime and to have the United
States go back which is perhaps and I
tend to think that what they in fact is
the president were hoping to be able to
do formerly at least led to bringing bad
the United Nations to the center of the
stage I'm not really so keen and nanika
is not yet because this has been said
already in fact we see the United
Nations caught in the permanent balance
of forces between different sovereign
states which tend to make it the
instrument of their own realpolitik what
this situation once again puts in full
clarity is the urgent necessity to
transform the United Nations themselves
trying to go beyond the control
exercised by the consortium of
powerful nations that arose from the
Second World War not only to reflect a
different international reality which
has been said very often but to actually
enter the era of a collective control of
armaments and conflicts we all know that
this is absolutely not likely to take
place rapidly not even Russia and the
United States are signatories of the
treatise on the International Criminal
Court which in this case would be
particularly indicated to say something
and do something so in the mean times
the Syrians will continue to die and at
the very least it's a reason to publicly
ask these questions each time we can
okay can the gun military intervention
be justified in the case of Syria for me
military intervention can be justified
if it meets to test at least it should
not undermine international law and it's
possible it should consolidate it the
first test and the second it should make
such situation better for the people in
my view military intervention in Syria
would fail both test and first test
international norms and of course if you
have a little historical memory you
remember the first UN investigation on
chemical weapons in the region that was
in nineteen eighty-four when Paris des
koala sent a team to Iraq after repeated
use of chemical weapons by Iraq against
Iran and that was before the use of
chemical weapons in Arab ja against the
Kurds and at the time the conclusion of
the investigation was that the European
countries that were providing precursors
to Iraq stopped
deliveries and that was the end of the
story there was no of course no talk of
intervention if you're Iranian you would
draw the conclusion that if there is an
issue of chemical weapons with a country
that is against Iran it's not so serious
if it is a country that is allied with
Iran it's a capital case this is this is
ana this is not a fundamental argument
but it's a historical context that
matters when one discusses the
consolidation of North because known
they also in the perception of the
beholder and the perception is shaped by
history you know by other factors too
but by history among among many factors
and norms as was as Jean Cohen said in
this case we have a conflict of several
norms we have a norm that has been more
as consolidated since the end of World
War two which is the article 51 of the
UN Charter that the use of forces in
self-defense or under the authority of
the Security Council this norm has been
violated as has the norm concerning
chemical weapons it has not been
violated too often at least to blatantly
by the p5
and in this particular case there is not
even know multi national organization
like the net NATO in the case of Kosovo
is not even a negotiation that developed
a set of norms on what needed to happen
there is not there's nothing like that
they're just essentially three countries
that believe that there is a sufficient
basis to intervene and that is that is
it so it's I'm not taking a position at
this stage would certainly require to
leap to decide that the norm of the
prohibition of chemical weapons is so
important that the other norm of how one
uses force can be dismissed in such a
Cavalier way it sits quite bye-bye p5 by
the by members of the p5 group which are
supposed to have a particular
responsibility in apple and upholding
the norms of the UN Charter it's serious
and the norm on the emerging norm of the
responsibility to protect it is an
emerging norm it is a norm that is
qualified in the in the document that
comes closest to a legal document which
has no legal authority the outcome
document of 2005 it is specifically
mentioned that it is under the authority
of the Security Council that collective
action would be taken so that consensus
of the summit of 2005 is no basis for
action absolutely not it goes way beyond
what was agreed in 2005 which is not a
resolution a Security Council just an
outcome document so and last no that's a
circumstantial argument it's quite
striking that the can
weapons became an issue when several
hundred people were killed it was it was
not raised as a big man it was raised by
France which on that point was more
coherent consistent than the US but it
was not raised by the US as a big as a
big issue before they were sub for 100
people and so that weakens the case
because it confuses the issue of
chemical weapons and the issue of the
mass killings in in Syria and if it's
the issue of mass killings obviously
conventional weapons have killed many
more people in very horrible ways and
have seen it then chemical weapons have
chemical weapons may have killed maybe
one percent compared to the other
weapons and so that raises the question
of the multiplicity of motives for
intervening in Syria and that
multiplicity of motives like in
alternative pleading weakens the case
rather than strengthen it and it brings
me to the second point which is will
intervention make things better and I
think that test is hard to pass we saw
in the embarrassed discussions in KY and
testimonies in Congress that on the one
hand we because there would not be
political support for that overwhelming
force is not at all considered to affect
regime change in the decisive way and
I'm a dog am not advocating for that by
the way but it's certainly not
considered so there is the idea of sort
of calibrating force so that it sends a
message but in the logic of deterrence
if you're not prepared to escalate
you're not credible and so if you send a
military message and if by if
unfortunately that message isn't
followed is not / and is not hurt then
you're bound to escalate otherwise you
really lost ever you have lost
everything and so if it is about
stopping chemical web
use the limited intervention is far from
a credible means if it is about ending
the conflict one has to be clear is it
about creating a military stalemate that
is supposed to that requires a kind of
fine-tuning of force and most military
would tell you that war is not something
that you find you and that the reality
is that use of force will harden the
positions of the parties give hope to
the opposition that indeed there is a
military solution it will not
precipitate a negotiation it will lead
to further military support on the other
side so it will lead to a protracted
conflict not to an accelerated
negotiation now let's imagine for one
second that there was the support for a
massive intervention a la Iraq and
indeed it's possible to bring down Assad
it could be done in a matter of weeks
I'm sure there's no question about that
now would the result be a good result it
is not at all clear you see now in Syria
more and more IDPs in the
government-controlled areas the Sunnis
who come to the government control areas
they don't like the government that
government is an abominable government
is one of the worst government on earth
but it is compared to the insecurity of
the rebel-held areas it's the least of
two evils and say they vote with their
feet
now and if there was in that I pathetic
all which is not going to happen it's
not going to be a massive intervention
in that I particle case if there was
such an intervention the reality is that
it would probably be lead to a second
wave of war between the various
components of the opposition unless you
one was prepared to establish really a
protectorate with massive occupation
which would lead to other problems so in
the end I believe that actually what has
happened where we have stumbled into
thanks to the cleverness of Lavrov who
may have had just in the idea of a
diversion in mind don't we don't know
it's too early to tell but it is
actually not the worst scenario by far
it does hold the possibility of some
progress on chemical weapons because the
Russians are always careful not to lose
credibility and so if they have gone out
on a limb on that issue it's probably
that they have some some understanding
with the Syrians that the student is
going to be serious with a chemical
weapon and that some progress can be
made because that progress can only be
limited unless there is something
broader because it's hard to see how you
can have effective chemical disarmament
in the midst of a shooting war so that
needs to lead to a broader agreement in
my view not between the Syrian
government and the opposition because I
don't think any negotiation is practical
at this stage between those parties but
rather within the Security Council on
shaping what an outcome would be it may
not happen because some regional
countries may want to derail that such
an outcome but that's it might be a much
better prospect for the people of Syria
than a military intervention
I thought I would say a little bit about
the on the argument that you commonly
hear these days that if the u.s. fails
to prevail on the Syrian chemical
weapons issue that it will have serious
reputational costs for the US for Obama
and for international normative regimes
at least about chemical weapons but
maybe responsibility to protect and
other good good norms that deserve to be
defended people argue that if Assad is
seen as getting away unpunished with
chemical weapons use that Iran will
conclude that the US doesn't mean what
it's saying in the threats that it makes
to Iran and that they will be more
likely to develop nuclear weapons that
the chemical weapons norm will be
severely tarnished and that other powers
will be more likely to use chemical
weapons and that Obama will be punished
in domestic politics because he drew the
the red line and then backed away from
that threat so I don't want to say that
you know none of these arguments make
any sense but i do want to present some
arguments that however much credit you
give to them when you leave the room
today I'd like you to like give them a
little less credit than you do at the
moment so I'm not going to say much of
anything about moral theories you know
being in a room where they're already
moral philosophers but consequentialism
is a principle in moral theory that
bought implies can and
includes ought implies that you can make
things better for the people concerned
but the parallel to that in just
positive theory is situational ism in
reputation making so whether we're
talking about psychologists in the
laboratory or international relations
scholars who study diplomacy people you
know who do research find that
reputational inferences are not just you
know one big undifferentiated oh he's
weak or oh he's strong but those kinds
of inferences take into account the
situation in which the actor is making
choices and deciding on a course of
action so if Obama the United States the
international community chooses not to
use military force in Syria despite
violations of international law or
morality it's likely that people will
draw the conclusion that it's not that
no one cared about the chemical weapons
norm it's more likely that they'll draw
the conclusion that there was nothing
constructive that could be done at the
moment with military force and that the
reputational consequences of that are
mitigating same thing is true when we
think about political leaders in a
democracy that make threats there's a
huge literature in political science
that argues that Democratic leaders who
make threats have an advantage in making
them credible because people that
are the targets of the threat will
realize that Democratic leaders will be
severely punished by their own public if
they don't carry out those threats well
that's really not true Democratic
leaders that make threats and then kind
of walk back from those threats
generally are not punished and one of
the major reasons for that is that the
public makes situational inferences to
the public gets upset if leaders don't
carry out their threats only if the
public was hawkish in the first place in
fact it historically the cases where
Democratic leaders make threat threats
and then have you know buyers regret for
often things like Kennedy and the Cuban
Missile Crisis where he was pushed by
very hawkish public opinion on the Cuba
issue to make his threats in in the
first place and that they punished the
leader because they want to use force
not because there was some discrepancy
between word and deed other political
science research looks at the question
of the why actors worry so much about
their reputation for standing firm in
international confrontations Jonathan
Mercer has written an excellent article
recently that argues that people worry
much more about their reputation for
standing firm than observers worried
about their reputation a case study that
he did was on the US concern to
a fearsome image towards the Chinese
during the Korean War to try to deter
the the Chinese from intervening in the
war but in fact what happened was not
that the Chinese didn't credit the US
with having firmness of resolve to use
force but in fact exactly the opposite
that the Chinese were so convinced that
the u.s. had aggressive intentions that
they decided to use force preemptively
themselves before the US could come and
get them on their own territory Ted huff
likewise has looked at at inferences
that the Soviets made after the u.s.
defeated withdrawal from the Vietnam War
did did the Soviets look at the US as a
week turn tail easy to push around and
Huff's book says that no the amazing
thing is how firmly the Soviets
continued to believe that the u.s. was
highly resolute highly credible was
looking hard to recoup its geopolitical
setbacks after the Vietnam War a slight
digression is the research findings on
in political science on the
effectiveness of aerial attacks that are
strictly to punish behavior not to
militarily win the war on the
battlefield Robert Papes definitive book
on this shows that punishment attacks
you know like those s Kabam in
escalation attacks in the Vietnam War
simply don't work you looked at you know
scores of cases they don't work what
works with their power is to actually
disarm the enemy
in the war a final point is that the
targets of the rats are often very
self-absorbed they're not focusing so
much on the threateners reputation they
have their own agenda though they're
concerned about the economy in Iran the
factional politics in Iran and as a
result they're they're looking at the
credibility of the threat through a kind
of perverse funhouse mirror in a way
that's just very different than the
reputation worry warts are thinking
about another another point is that with
a the domino theory the theory that if
we don't stand firm in one case then
people will consider that we will back
down in every case in the dominoes will
topple so who invented the domino theory
it was eisenhower after the French lost
North Vietnam at the Battle of Dien Bien
Phu and Eisenhower used the domino
theory not to say we should do something
really stupid and try to retake DN bien
phu in order to show that we can stand
firm no he said a domino has fallen
therefore we need to make extra efforts
to shore up the next Domino so that the
dominoes won't fall so let me finish
with that
already so what she was clec some
questions and focus them and I think in
fact i'm going to write off now turn
this over to Chris as I fortunately have
to go where we were taping this so we're
going to will have a record of it as
well say that my own gratification thank
you thank you so much Chris okay um i
would also like to thank everyone for
taking part in the panel this panel of
took shape with the number of fits and
starts and everyone was very patient so
i appreciate that actually i think maybe
we should start by asking if any of the
panelists would like to respond to each
other I think that's probably pretty
likely given the mix that we would
immediately want to jump they should
open up all right all right then let's
let's start with the audience
the remarks
I think that number I mean my senses
there was a consensus on
or even wanted a variety of raisins or
sort of more
realpolitik reasons maybe with this site
inspections Stewart that it's not a job
it's not a more collective best
interests
to use force 11 normal inherit that do
come on was that self-determination and
I wonder if any of the panel's believe
that there is something to learn about
this case because there
a revolutionary formation which was
fairly clearly articulated office
complex popular meant to overthrow the
regime does that matter at all is there
any comparative to support watch
entourage
and is there if not just supportive is
there any imperative to not undermined
and might for example proposal of the
Russians in which it seems that regime
could actually be strengthened or
perhaps preserved by turning over summer
math
which one it seems without a business
the revolutionary project does that
factor in the hell up so to repeat for
the mic I think that sort of the heart
of the question is is there imperative
to support or at least not to weaken the
norm of self-determination we want to
respond or jack no it depends on what
you mean by self-determination in this
context if you mean self-determination
of peoples I think it's irrelevant
because the Syrian people are not a
people and you know it's it's so doesn't
apply if you mean democracy like
literally a democratic process and
outcome in Syria nobody expects that to
happen no matter you know what the
course of the fighting is over the
foreseeable future so that doesn't
really apply you give me Jen not if
people the the the Syrian people have I
think demonstrated a lack of agreement
on who is the we that would exercise
national self-determination so I mean
maybe there are people i mean i'm not
the international law expert in on the
panel but maybe they're people if you
think that like any collectivities
individuals that resides inside the
boundaries of something that
national community has designated as an
estate our people but if you're taking
it as a social science proposition about
nationalism and the likely effectiveness
that people can coalesce and form a self
determining nation the Syrians aren't it
yeah dummy oh no we're good I want I
want to add something for that I agree
with Jack but I think the problem is
though it isn't is maybe some of the
presuppositions of the question first
I'm revolutionary I don't know what that
means for you you know shooting each
other civil war all kinds of things are
going on and you don't a revolution I
don't think it's an apt description I
think right now an apt description of
what's going on in series of civil war
and of course as at timber I said
there's an already intervention from all
sides but I I would affirm that first
why did mention self-determination as
one of us one of the principles but that
was with respect to external imposition
and the problem of what happened livia
even if you intervene then you're not
supposed to impose that's part of
international law too but I agree that
right now it's not that the Syrian
people isn't a people in the sense that
the Syrian state had its addressees
namely the citizens citizenry of Syria
but that that in a civil war that's
that's also it's contested who is the
people and by the way no one no instance
no group in a sense of claiming to be
the people is the people the people has
to be understood as a pluralist as a
pluralist agglomeration of many
different groups interest factions etc
although and in that sense the word to
say that the revolution isn't by the
people as opposed to X anybody can play
that game and that's that's partly you
know fans the flames of Civil War so I
think that that this is this is not the
right lens with which to view what's
going on
now and I would add that indeed it
should be among our guiding principles
that any solution that would allow the
people of Syria to have a voice we
should assure me that should be one of
the goals and if it is one of the goals
I think it's it's reasonable to say that
any military solution whether it be a
victory of the regime or victory of the
various positions will not be to that
thank you very much more interesting
comments
hear that it is a sense of consensus
that that
the intervention the type of
intervention on the table that could
years more advanced in starkville year
the alternatives
we also need a larger consensus here
that Syrian cases of beer
but what is the best that can be done at
this point bye
community and a special
moral principle here especially and
ethically we take first to know hard as
they round
prism
I love you
so in a nutshell what would be the
alternatives to to military intervention
in particular right and keeping in mind
particularly and impaired to do no harm
I was I was a graduate student here in
the 90s when the rwanda genocide went on
so we were all aware of everything
reading the newspapers every day and
then and then all of a sudden 800,000
people were dead and for the next you
know going on 20 years we're saying half
of the world have watched that happen
and did nothing and i'm not a big
interventionist so I'm not as much of an
outlier in this panel I critiqued the
libby intervention so we have to
remember that the only point I was
making was that a credible use of force
doesn't necessarily have to just come
for the UN Security Council it's the
only point that I was making so we're
going to are we going to look back at
I've had two years of classes now with
the serious civil war going on and every
fall and now we're on the third on the
second fall but also my spring classes
every semester we're racking up another
10,000 another twelve thousand other
fifteen thousand and they say and no
one's really even aware of what's going
on but we're going to look back in five
years and maybe they're going to be half
a million dead and we're going to have a
lot of these very important
philosophical discussions of why we have
to uphold norms and protect this and
establish that and yet there are mass
graves and there are women getting
gang-raped and this chemical weapons
being used I don't have all the answers
all I know is that when we look back the
world is going to again ask what did the
world do when hundreds of thousands of
people died right on Twitter and right
on YouTube with the entire world
watching there are difficult answers to
the question of what's the alternative
and we hear all different kinds of
things some say just let them burn out
there are you know Shiite
revolutionaries against Sunni
revolutionaries there's some jihadis on
the ground in Iran versus Saudi Arabia
are sort of the big players battling it
out and what's wrong with a protect a
protracted civil war where they where
it's sort of a war of attrition and the
answer is the Syrian people are caught
in the crossfire you know I don't have
all of the answers to the question of
what are the alternatives but
we see the headlines every day and I
think that outside of the bouncers just
the UN Security Council prism we have to
think of other outside the box how is it
going about this well I don't know if
you want to answer this but I mean
sometimes all sometimes there are two
beds or many beds and now good that's
just sometimes how it is and if I agree
with what was said by my French college
if if if you cannot see an additional
intervention having positive outcomes
but rather Fanning the flames then then
that's a serious problem and in this
case well I mean I would I think that
there are other kinds of sanctions I
think that there are there should be a
great deal of writing and pressure
exerted wherever it could be exerted to
get the major players the the on the
council and elsewhere to bring people to
it to a table because in ultimately we
know the only way that this is going to
be solved is it that's done and so yeah
I mean it's it's it's it's morally
horrible but I don't see a morally
better alternative through military
intervention right now now I mean of
course if this whole thing that with
with with Russia if this is a game and
then and if for example chemical weapons
are used again or some other form of
drastic masculine occurs then I mean it
might get us to the point with
international community comes together
what if the UN Security Council blocks
it again I said the international
community comes together and and as I
said in my presentation it might get you
to the point where there is a much
broader group and broader consensus that
okay and you now something else has to
be done and if one state vetoes it and
by the way I'm glad to see that you're
well I mean I understand the problems
with the veto structure in the US in the
Security Council I'm you know ignorant
of that problem but in any case if that
occurs then then the constellation of
situation changes but as a right this
right now this very moment what would
you do my response not just behalf of
second why she wanted the Jean Marie was
yes well and I think there are sodium in
there there are potential way positive
ways to go forward I think if we had had
that discussion 18 months ago some
negotiation between Syrians if it had
the support of the international
community of the p5 could have produced
results and I think the the rhetoric of
intervention and the sort of shadow
position especially Western countries
didn't help because they align
themselves with the regional divided
without seeing that there are better
ways I think today a negotiation between
Syrians is not a realistic prospect and
so I think today there's much greater
responsibility of the Security Council
it's possible M&A and there's no
alternative to a much more decisive role
of this evening also in shaping the
solution I think it's not impossible
that considering the alternatives both
United States and Russia see that a
protracted conflict will not only lead
to many more casualties much more than
what we have it so far but also will
spill over throughout the region and
will become completely uncontrollable
and be really callus traffic and that
the agreement that the framework
agreement that they have reached on
chemical weapons may be the basis for
broader
agreements between them on what a
process should be which would probably
entail at some point elections there's
an electoral calendar of Syria that
provides for a presidential election in
2014 and legislative election in 2016
now of course it's hard to imagine the
present circumstances how that would
take place the sequence is something
that pleases the Syrian government
because they believe they would win the
presidential election well they would
have a harder time with the digestive
election so there's a room there for
discussion adjustments but when you
think of how the Cambodian situation was
resolved with Raymond Khmer Rouge were
they were not easy group and
nevertheless one man in this event REE
laid the foundation for something that
is far from perfect but that certainly
ended a horrible period in the history
of Cambodia so I think the possibility
of the City Council coming together is
not an in complete pie in the sky I
think it's it's a real possibility I
think if that doesn't happen probably
the alternative scenario further
fragmentation of Syria leading to
fragmentation of the region and a
redrawing of the math of the Middle East
is the most likely and it's catastrophic
and I don't think we can do much about
it
so I think it's important to take a
really long view of this sort of problem
sometimes there are problems that don't
have a short run solution but that
doesn't necessarily mean that in general
the world is going to hell in a
handbasket and that the the powers don't
have a strategy to make things better so
there's a big literature in political
science right now about the obsolescence
of war and i don't mean international
war i mean civil war as well you know
you look at the numbers that the numbers
of wards are going down the numbers of
civilian casualties from civil wars are
going down this kind of a debate about
what this means why it's happening when
you know whether it's just a blip but
something seems to be going on and it's
probably has something to do with the
diffusion of democracy of the
strengthening and maintenance of the
international trading system
improvements in how peacekeeping is done
and so that doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be some serious that
just can't be fixed but it means that on
average somebody seems to be doing
something right so far the adsorption
cell
department so far the sentiment seems to
be the that there are overwhelming
Prudential reasons for not going ahead
with a punitive strike or however you
conceive of the strike and I wanted to
possibly add one more to those which is
I wonder how seriously to take Assad
threat that if there is a us-led strike
on Syria that he would retaliate by
targeting allies of the u.s. that is
Israel and Turkey and obviously that in
turn raises the question of NATO
escalation right an aggression against a
native aggression against NATO member
drawing the broader alliance each you
Warren and that brings portal
but that would be an escalation and I
just wonder if any of the panels would
weigh in on how that might figure Assad
has made mistakes from his standpoint
but he is he's on the whole a rational
actor sometimes makes misjudgments but
does not engage in action that is
obviously against his interest I think
for instance the chemi the use of
chemical weapons I'm sure is that this
was something that was decided that the
eyes level but the the impact probably
was miscalculated most likely no no no
way to tell but and the fact that
previous actions with chemical weapons
had met with no response so consolidated
the idea that this it was agreed
something that would not have major
consequence that's a miscalculation I
think in the deliberate action to target
NATO NATO country like the US or to
target Israel when I was a real-life
sorry the turkey or to target Israel
it's quite remarkable that when there
was the humiliation of the Israeli
strike in Syria nothing happened because
regime knows very well that Israel has
overwhelming power and can crush him at
any time and so I think they're aware of
that and there would be other ways to to
retaliate rather than that I think an
argument that hasn't been mentioned
against rice's the broader context of
Iran and that at the moment when there
is a slight hope of going through a
diplomatic solution with Iran which is
the only possible solution military
strike in Syria would make that prospect
which is a fragile way which may not
which can we make up to nothing but
which is very important one in
strategically enormously important that
would be seriously damaged if not made
impossible that's a very strong argument
against military strike it might be and
let's take a half a step back this
strike that was supposed to go after
Assad was described by John Kerry as
going to be a quote unbelievably small
attack so I don't want we shouldn't
overstate the destructive power of this
strike that was going to lash out to
some kind of a self-destructive act of
retaliation by Assad that would have
brought down the entire israeli air
force upon damascus the alternative is
more likely which is why I don't happen
to subscribe that the threat of the use
of force is what brought about the whole
Lavrov agreement all the rest Assad
would have benefited if these strikes
took place if they were unbelievably
small he survived and was celebrated for
having survived an american-led strike
against him he was a pinprick attack he
wasn't going to come out of that in any
way in my opinion harmed he was going to
be if anything you know it was going to
be good PR against united states in the
region for probably there's going to be
going to be some civilian deaths one way
or another there's gonna be a PR
catastrophe for the United States and
probably a PR boon for Assad which is I
think part of the calculus not because
of the threat he was going to lash out
but because they saw if it was that
limited it was probably not going to
have much benefit other than they
followed through on the threat Jack I
mean they they drew this red line
whether you're right about the political
science or not the discussions in the
White House were my credibility
on the line and if I don't act or
threaten to act the Republicans and the
media and everyone else is going to you
know in this democracy are going to jump
all over all over him on that point so
he was caught up and he tripped over his
own red line but I wouldn't make it seem
like that red line was ever going to be
anything he didn't want to attack
clearly and if they were going to attack
as we very limited he do not want to
topple Assad he does not want to get
involved with the civil war in a deeper
way so i was going to always be limited